bom eu vejo um monte de palestra muito
legal aqui e deixei um cara aqui com uma
camiseta chuba que cursava física e o
mais legal de tudo é que as pessoas
sempre confundem física ou educação
física
eu tenho uma pequena diferença né e
apesar de eu não ter cursado a educação
física eu acredito que alguns momentos
da nossa vida são como o pedal de
bicicleta e para muito longe pedalando
a primeira vez que eu fui para nova york
eu cheguei lá de bicicleta eu pedalei
160 quilômetros de filadélfia nova york
e quando eu falei pra minha mãe mãe a
minha primeira vez que vou para nova
york eu vou de bicicleta pedalando
você tá louco pra muito longe vai de
ônibus a primeira vez que se vê o quão
longe que é de se desiste
bom eu cheguei em nova york e eu me
senti mais ou menos dessa maneira porque
160 quilômetros para quem não estava
acostumado a pedalar é algo realmente
muito desafiador é muito difícil eu me
sentir mais ou menos dessa maneira
quando me inscrevi no programa sem
fronteiras do governo federal para
estudar na universidade da pensilvânia
nos estados unidos
e esse intercâmbio que eu fiz realmente
mudou a minha vida e mudou tanto que
quando eu voltei para o brasil eu
desistir da carreira acadêmica e criei
uma revista de tecnologia e ciência para
universitários
apesar de um monte de gente me falar não
faça é suicídio vai dar errado revista
impressa hoje em dia não funciona mais
na era digital e uma das primeiras
coisas que me marcou nesse intercâmbio
era que lá na universidade da
pensilvânia é muito fácil se matricular
em matéria de outros departamentos e
isso fez com que eu da física e
matricular se em matéria de várias áreas
e aprender muita coisa que eu não teria
aprendido aqui no brasil eu também notei
que muitas há muitas dessas classes
tinham alunos de várias áreas do
conhecimento também assistindo aulas
juntos e os professores também sempre
buscavam
mostrar como várias áreas do
conhecimento interagiam para chegar um
determinado resultado
e aí eu percebi que hoje a tecnologia ea
ciência não se faz mais dentro de
departamentos
essa troca de conhecimentos e essa
interdisciplinaridade é fundamental
se a gente quiser desenvolver tecnologia
e ciência de ponta e uma outra coisa que
eu percebi lá nos estados unidos é que
em geral o aluno americano e muito
artigo científico e eu percebi isso na
prática fez uma matéria lá em que eu
precisava no trabalho final de conclusão
desta matéria precisava ler cinco
artigos científicos e escrever um artigo
científico com base em dados sobre o
assunto fazendo uma revisão do assunto
isso é uma matéria de calouros aqui no
brasil se um aluno não lhe artigo
científico é capaz de se formar sem
nunca ter contato com o artigo é e
também nos estados unidos é desculpa é
essa leitura de artigos científicos é
essencial pra que as pessoas estejam
atualizadas e a par do que realmente
está acontecendo na ciência e também foi
lá nos estados unidos que eu tive as
melhores aulas da minha vida eu me
matriculei em uma matéria de
empreendedorismo para engenharia e essa
matéria fez toda a diferença pra mim eu
aprendi lá realmente como dar o primeiro
passo no empreendedorismo
então aprendi conceitos de marketing
produto a mercado financeiro liderança e
e isso fez realmente toda a diferença
para mim então ao mesmo tempo que essa
foi uma das matérias que mais agregou
pra mim foi também uma das que mais
exigiu de mim porque toda terça feira eu
precisava de 30 páginas de conteúdo e
escrever uma redação de duas páginas e
entregar em sala toda quinta-feira mais
30 páginas e fazer uma resposta um curso
na sala de aula no começo da aula e
quando o professor explicou essa
dinâmica no começo do primeiro dia de
aula pensei esse cara tá doido vou
desistir dessa matéria é muito difícil
eu como brasileiro não estava acostumado
a essa dinâmica de estudos e eu não me
arrependo realmente de tv
o que realmente mudou minha vida também
nos estados unidos
eu assisti a uma palestra com o diretor
de um banco de investimentos
e ele falou sobre gratidão e segundo ele
existem três formas de gratidão você
fazer doações fazer trabalho voluntário
e empreender e lá também é muito comum
que os alunos depois de se formar em
eles devolvam prostituição eles façam
doações para a universidade onde
estudaram
isso é uma forma de demonstrar que eles
são gratos pelo que eles aprenderam e
que eles querem que a universidade
continue com o trabalho e aí eu parei
pra pensar poxa o estudo de graça no
brasil uma universidade federal e eu tô
aqui no exterior também estudando de
graça pelo programa sem fronteiras
eu preciso fazer alguma coisa pra
devolver para a sociedade todo esse
investimento que está sendo feito em mim
e eu gostava muito de tecnologia e
ciência sempre gostei muito porque eu
acredito que essas são as áreas que têm
maior potencial para causar
transformações positivas na sociedade e
eu também gostava um pouco de escrever e
gostava muito de design gráfico então e
com essa vontade de empreender de
devolver para a sociedade surgiu a idéia
de criar uma revista de tecnologia e
ciência para aproximar os estudantes de
várias áreas do conhecimento e para
fazer com que eles fossem além da sala
de aula
então quando eu voltei para o brasil eu
conversei com dois colegas do
laboratório do fábio raul e arrasou
jakubiak e juntos nós começamos essa
revista
então essas aulas de empreendedorismo
que assistindo os estados unidos
realmente me ajudaram a dar os primeiros
passos
então nós começamos fazendo algumas
entrevistas é primeiro com professores e
um dos primeiros professores que a gente
entrevistou nos falou bem assim
olha a idéia de vocês é muito nobre mas
não vai dar certo
o aluno brasileiro não gosta de ler
ele não leu o texto obrigatória para a
sala de aula e aí ouvi alguém falando
que não vai dar certo
antes mesmo de você começar
pode ser muito traumático mas bom eu já
falei para vocês que eu gostava física e
não é traumático para quem cursa física
o experimento nunca dá certo nunca
funciona
não funciona na primeira vez não
funciona na segunda na terceira na 100ª
e de verdade eu tenho um colega que fez
mestrado e são dois anos o experimento
dele só começou a funcionar faltando
cinco meses para ele realmente defendeu
dissertação
você imagina correria fazendo medida tal
para tirar o resultado uma correria mas
enfim a física ensina que saber que não
vai dar certo não há motivo para não
tentar
e então a gente continuar nessa pesquisa
a entrevistando alguns alunos ea gente
queria realmente entender se os alunos
teriam interesse nesse negócio e ea
foram algumas conversas informais com os
estudantes que a gente usou para
realmente testar a viabilidade do
negócio
então a nós conseguimos confirmar
algumas hipóteses e o que a gente
descobriu foi mais ou menos assim o
estudante brasileiro em geral não lhe
artigo científico
ele não ler sobre áreas distintas da
qual estuda um estudante de engenharia
civil nunca vai ler um artigo de
biologia
ele só se informa sobre tecnologia e
ciência em portais de notícias e por
mídias sociais
ele gostaria de receber nossa revista
mas só se fosse de graça
e aí a gente tinha um problema né a
gente precisa fazer uma revista no
méxico é de graça e bom a gente começou
a fazer a revista ea gente pois o fez a
revista de forma que ela abordasse
conteúdos que são publicadas em artigos
científicos mas de uma forma mais
simplificada com uma linguagem mais
próxima do estudante e também a de uma
forma que conectasse diversas áreas e aí
a idéia então a partir dessas
entrevistas era distribuir as revistas
gratuitamente dentro de universidades
para alunos dos cursos de gente de
engenharia ciências exatas e saúde ea
revista tinha que ser de graça ea gente
ia arranjar dinheiro de algum lugar para
sustentar isso imprimir uma revista não
é nem um pouco barato então pra começar
eu vendi meu carro e o fábio últimas
economias na poupança pegou e
gil também ea gente imprime a primeira
edição em setembro de 2013 isso foi mais
ou menos três meses após voltar do
intercâmbio e nós investimos nosso
próprio dinheiro para imprimir suíça
esses exemplares e distribuímos dessa
revista gratuitamente em quatro
universidades de curitiba foram 10 mil
exemplares na primeira edição e a agente
recebe alguns feedbacks de alunos e de
professores falando que o nosso trabalho
tava bom e que era pra gente continuar
só que assim a gente não tinha dinheiro
era o nosso próprio dinheiro e a gente
continuou com o nosso próprio dinheiro
mesmo sabendo que a gente a gastar mais
um monte de dinheiro
bom a verdade que a gente então fez uma
tradição e a gente começou a receber
muito feedback dos alunos dos
professores a gente precisa financiar a
revista eo jeito de financiar que a
gente encontrou foi vendendo anúncios
fazendo publicidade e no começo a gente
ligou para muita empresa pra muita
indústria e assim foram pelo menos umas
500 ligações logo no começo da revista e
mails enviados ea gente descobrir uma
outra coisa muito importante
só que trabalha com marketing muito
ocupada eles têm o dia inteiro se ligava
os 10 até reunião ligado às 11h em
reunião a meio dia para almoçar duas da
tarde
outra reunião e assim as poucas pessoas
que a gente conseguiu conversar nos
falar mais ou menos do que a gente já
vinha ouvindo um bom tempo
não obrigada a gente não tem interesse
implicitamente falando olha não vai dar
certo mas mesmo assim na primeira edição
a gente conseguiu vender um anúncio sem
ter nenhuma revista impressa e eu lembro
que quando eu fui chamar os meus colegas
pra trabalhar e escolher derrubando toda
para trabalhar comigo fala me disse olha
eu já vendi anúncio lista telefônica e
vai ser nossa igualzinho de ela não ser
revisto né
não era ele percebeu isso mas ele
consegue vender um anúncio sem a gente
tem uma revista provou que ele era um
bom vendedor pelo menos
ah então a gente conseguiu vender um
anúncio na primeira edição mas realmente
a cada nova edição que a gente estava
publicando a gente a receita com
publicidade estava aumentando mas mesmo
assim a gente estava gastando muito mais
dinheiro para imprimir do que estava
retardando ea gente percebeu que não ia
muito longe desse jeito não ia dar muito
certo
só que por outro lado cada vez mais a
gente estava recebendo avaliações
positivas de alunos e de professores
falando que o nosso trabalho estava
muito bom e que era pra gente continuar
e que era um trabalho importante
então quando nós lançamos a quarta
edição da revista
nós criamos uma campanha de crowdfunding
e lançamos escrevemos alguns textos e
gravamos alguns vídeos
é para essa campanha nós pedimos 62 mil
reais nessa campanha para financiar as
próximas edições da revista ea verdade é
que a gente conseguiu nove mil e numa
campanha de crowdfunding se você não
atingir a meta
você não leva nada a gente conseguiu 226
colaboradores 9 mil reais
mas no final das contas isso foi igual a
zero ou seja a gente voltou à estaca
zero sem dinheiro sem o que fazer e
sabendo que a revista tinha futuro
então pra não acabar com a revista o que
sei fazer alguns empréstimos e tem
realmente quando o dinheiro dos
empréstimos acabaram e as parcelas
começar a vencer
eu preciso começar o estágio mas sem
abandonar a revista e junto com essa
campanha de crowdfunding
nós resolvemos contar nossa história a
gente começou a escrever alguns textos e
publicar no nosso site
contando com a revista surgiu a partir
do programa sem fronteiras
quais eram os nossos objetivos e como
que a gente estava atuando nas
universidades
isso fez muito sucesso as pessoas
começaram a se identificar com a nossa
história se identificar com o nosso
propósito identificar com os problemas
que a gente identificou dentro da
universidade e começar a nos procurar e
alguns desses textos que a gente
publicou tiveram mais de 50 mil acessos
então a contar nossa história fez com
que as pessoas quisessem receber a nossa
revista
e mais do que isso algumas empresas
começaram a nos procurar para oferecer
patrocínio
então a gente aprendeu realmente que
contar nossa história melhor forma de
mostrar o nosso trabalho e embora a
nossa gigantesca equipe de três pessoas
ainda escreva a maioria dos artigos
a gente tem recebido cada vez mais
colaborações de alunos e de professores
de todo o brasil e desde o começo a
gente sempre publicou a revista impressa
no nosso site e online gratuito e mas o
que os alunos realmente querem a revista
impressa ea gente percebe isso quando a
gente publica a um post com as duas
versões então agente público o link pra
versão digital têm em média 30 a 40
curtidas uma foto de alguém distribuindo
a revista impressa dentro de uma
universidade tem 150 partidas e não só
isso mas vários comentários de alunos de
outras instituições que ainda não
recebem a revista pedindo para receber e
como eu falei nós começamos em curitiba
em quatro universidades e depois dessa
desse extenso desta campanha os alunos
começaram a nos procurar e um aluno dia
da universidade federal de uberlândia
frederico nos procurou e falou andré a
gente quer receber essa revista quer
distribuir aqui e um tempo depois ele me
falou andré olha vocês mandar essa
revista pra gente realiza um sonho nosso
e mais uma coisa tem um professor que
nos escreveu falando que ele é um artigo
na nossa revista e que isso despertou
uma ideia que estava dormente na mente
dele sobre uma pesquisa que ele poderia
desenvolver e o artigo que nós
publicamos na nossa revista fez com que
ele escrevesse um artigo científico em
colaboração com dois pesquisadores de
fora do país
isso tudo mostra pra gente que a gente
está indo no caminho certo em que a
gente está conseguindo realmente mudar
as universidades e há hoje nós
distribuímos a revista em mais de 60
universidades de todo o brasil para uma
revista que não ia dar certo
só em quatro universidades em dois anos
menos de dois anos estamos em 60
universidades e
e assim embora eu perceba que muitas
pessoas falaram no começo que não é dar
certo e que era pra gente desistir
se a gente realmente tivesse existido
nas primeiras vezes que nos botaram para
baixo ou quando falaram que não ia dar
certo ou quando surgiram as primeiras
segundas centésimas dificuldades a gente
nunca teria aprendido acertar
eu realmente acho que a gente está
aprendendo a aceitar e o que a gente vê
com os nossos leitores nos mostra isso
que nós estamos aceitando e hoje a eu há
uns dois meses a fazer um estágio eu
recebi uma proposta para ser efetivado
neste estágio
e então eu pude por causa desse projeto
que nós criamos recusar a vaga para ser
efetivado eu não recusei a vaga como
também pediu o cancelamento do meu
estágio e vocês podem imaginar a cara da
minha namorada né
o que você recusou um cai no emprego com
carteira assinada se tá doida pra fazer
uma revista impressa
né enfim a gente vê de pouco em pouco a
gente está realmente conseguindo
conectar diferentes áreas do
conhecimento está conseguindo fazer com
que os alunos vão além do conteúdo que
eles vêm em sala de aula ea gente
acredita que de pouco em pouco a gente
vai conseguir transformar a educação no
brasil mas principalmente a gente
acredita que essa é uma forma da gente
devolver para a sociedade um pouco de
tudo aquilo que a gente recebeu muito
obrigado